welcome back to the David Pakman show. Okay,
let's get back to the phone. (617) 830-4750
last show before the 4th of July. Break.
Checking in with people and seeing what is
on people's minds. Let's go to our caller
from the five oh two area code. Call her from
five oh two. What's your name? Where are you
calling from?
Yeah.
Hello? Yes, that's you.
Um, yes, I, I'm Poloma and I'm in Kentucky.
Um, thanks for taking my call. Uh, I was just,
uh, there's this guy on a called Bob TV. There's
a lot of progressive.
All right, so hold on. You're, you're, you're
breaking up. You're talking about a you per
youtube or named what? Bob TV.
Bob TV is the name of the channel. Okay. Um,
and there a, uh, mean that you in passing
along basically trying to say that Kamala
Harris was not subject to segregation because
she was, uh, she started going to school after
the integration had already, uh, came up.
It says this little girl was born in 64. She
didn't start school cause she was six and
69. Uh, she didn't start riding a bus till
73 when she was nine and they had not been
segregated since 1943 and I tried to do some
digging and I really couldn't find anything
really definitive seeing as how it was like
a state of state type thing. I, I guess. Uh,
and I was wondering if you knew anything in
regards to that.
No, I don't. So here, this is a really good
example based on what I've been talking about
recently regarding not getting overly involved
in arguments where once you settle the argument,
it doesn't really tell you what what you do
next. So I guess the, the argument that's
being made is based on when, I don't know
cow, Kamala Harris I believe is from California
and I guess she went to school somewhere in
California when she was a kid. Is that right?
Okay. So the argument is that even though,
even though there was not a, a sort of a final
end point of full desegregation of schools
until later on in the 20th century, the argument
is that in the particular place where Kahmilah
Harris went to school, there had been desegregation
before she started going to school. Therefore
she was not a victim of segregation. That
that's sort of the argument that, that you're
repeating was made, right? Yeah. So then the
question is, and so what, what is the argument
is the idea that Camilla Harris is wrong on
policy because she either was or was not at
a segregated school? Like, this is why we
have to be thinking about it. Number one,
I haven't even heard her talk about this.
So if she's claiming she went to segregated
schools,
I think the largest argument in that was to,
uh, was to show that it was kind of like trying
to be an opportunist for a gotcha moment.
Yeah. I mean this is sort of like, listen,
if you, let me give you an example Poloma
because I think that this is, um, if you,
if your family left World War Two with no
money right before you were sent to a concentration
camp in 1939 or whatever, uh, and then you
go out and you talk about the Holocaust and
you talk about antisemitism, um, should we
say, you know, you, you technically left right
before you would've been sent to the concentration
camp and killed, therefore you can't talk
about this issue. I mean, I just don't understand
what the, what, what do we gain by by doing
that. And that's why I think it's like, who
cares? You know, is her policy right on these
issues or is it wrong? Is she well positioned
to take on, um, uh, the interests that are
negatively influencing the country? That's
what I care about.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And that's one thing that I've
been focused on as well is, uh, really from
my perspective, the only two truly progressive
people right now are Tulsi Gabbert and Bernie.
But they both had their problematic past that
they also have acknowledged. But Kamala Harris,
she didn't show any regret. She had not conveyed
any regret and the things that she had done
in support of mass incarceration. So that's
one of one of my biggest concerns.
Yeah, that's a problem. That's why I've talked
about that before. I have not seen her sort
of account for her role there. Um, I take
issue with the idea that Sanders and Gabbert
are the most progressive of the, of the Democratic
candidates. Running Gabbert actually has one
of the highest percentages in which she votes
with the Trump position on issues in the last
congress. So I've not seen any empirical evidence
that she's one of the most progressive. It
seems to be. Um, uh, at least on voting for
Trump. I believe it's jeweler brand. Bernie
and Warren who least often vote with Trump.
That's just one measure though. Um, but Poloma
thank you for the call. I'm going to let you
go a a look into the Camila thing, but I just
wouldn't even worry about it too much cause
it's mostly irrelevant.
All right. Thanks again.
And to be clear, I'm not talking about her
role in the prison industrial complex. I'm
talking about whether or not she, you know,
went to a segregated school. Poloma thank
you, great to hear from you. Appreciate the
phone call.